one of the things you said that was
disturbingly misleading is the ending of
the documentary and the the ending
has a phone call i think yeah of you and
anthony talking so what high level let
me ask
uh how many times have you talked
with anthony since you got
out of prison and what did you talk
about and why is that
quote misleading
that uh uh segment of audio misleading
my issue with it also was that it was
deliberately misleading which was
what was particularly
um infuriating about it infuriating
about it
um
and then also there was
it was like there were thing
one major thing that was incorrect that
i think
helped allow people to make an incorrect
conclusion at the end was um
in the in the film it talks about i say
something about how my accountant made a
joke about if i married him he could
easily transfer me money without tax
consequences and then
the film has me saying something like
you know
and then within 24 hours we were married
but that's like audio from here and
audio from here spliced together so they
made it seem
like there's like i married him because
it was like he could give me money and
that wasn't the case so you're
part mastermind of some kind of scheme
that involve
money transfer and you got married and
that kind of right or if nothing else i
had like i was trying to get money
that's why i married him so
which is absurd because again you know
new york is full of legitimate people
with loads of money if i really wanted
to marry somebody for money in new york
it wouldn't be that hard to do
but anyway it was like it was just a
deliberate
making it seem like my intention was you
know to marry him for
his fictitious money right um okay so
that's one and either way let's go to
that ending thing because because we're
on that sort of topic because
when you got out of prison
you know the what the film implies is
that
whatever there's a small aspect of your
mind that still wants to continue a
relationship with anthony yeah that's
not the case and
not just that but there's still
flirtation and that kind of
a body and collide
like
we got the the world
like at our fingertips we're playing
so i mean one of the exciting things
about being
like a couple that's [ __ ] with the
world that's getting away with something
is that
there's all these powerful forces that
want to catch you
in a crime and you keep getting away
with it that's exciting
in some
[Music]
world it could be although not in this
case
right and also i always have to keep
reminding people like get away with what
because i lost everything and all these
people lost other you know
people i cared about lost a lot
my mother lost a lot
but i lost everything too yeah your um
your restaurant
and all my dream
yeah my reputation my stuff
my home
you know
ending up with millions of dollars of
debt like it's not even like i lost it
all and it's a clean slate it's like i
lost it all and now i have this like
giant
boulder of
or like this wobbly
unclear how to like yeah so when people
say
well sisyphus got a thing away with
something i'm always like got away with
what i know describing my life and
ending up in debt because that's it's
not even like
you can't even sort of
point to like
as if i was trying to do something and
then oops that happened it's like
there's no
nothing that logically makes sense if
somebody was trying to
um
uh decipher
my you know whatever motives i might
have had yeah you didn't walk away from
the explosion you were inside the
explosion
okay
but that said the movie implied and so i
mean it's interesting to ask
um not just
in
and clarifying the movie but just as a
human being
you're out of prison he's out of prison
there was
you know there was that
um toxic connection but it was there
and there was a depth to it so toxic
connections can be pretty deep
so
how what what was the conversation like
and how often have you talked with him
well we don't speak anymore um and
that call on at the end was even on g
chat recorded
was recorded on like i recorded the call
and gave it to them you know so i was
like deliberately recording him it's not
like i was caught on a hot mic like i
made that call it's part of the doctor i
recorded him intentionally i was trying
to get him to repeat some of like the
kookier things he would say about
like his meat suit or
some of the weird like
the things about
something not being real
the more like fantastical things i was
trying to get him to repeat those things
it was probably like a 40-minute call
which i mean it's actually on my phone i
still have it i haven't gone back to
listen to it but you ever think of
publishing that whole thing oh yeah oh i
think about publishing everything my
entire journal all you should publish
that call unedited just publish it that
would be fun no that i want to publish
like a lot of stuff
he took all these videos of me also that
they used a couple of clips of and i
would yeah i mean i would they're also
on my phone i would publish them all i
would publish everything
in particular
um because you should release that with
your book skip
yeah
i probably i mean i've planned to do
that
eventually if all of that material would
be really useful to um
psychologists or people studying it so
to the extent that it would help other
people understand what happened
um which is he's still out there meaning
his fault
yeah he's still out there doing weird
weird [ __ ]
with his clean slate
i get a little annoyed about that
he's got the clean slate well he didn't
have a
restaurant he didn't have a persona
does he have any public persona or no or
we don't know he got booted off of
twitter
will put him back on
is that a passive aggressive thing no
not at all i i find that whole
conversation really really interesting
um whether to put somebody like anthony
on back on twitter well no i think
because i used to always think like if
only
everybody had to identify as themselves
on twitter and you could have like a
parody account yeah or like like leon
has an account but it's very clear that
it's me behind it or sometimes there's
like
you know devin nunes
like so people have parody accounts but
but if we could identify who it is
then
um
a lot of why did he get booted off of
twitter
i don't know but i used to so in the
last few years i would periodically
probably like once a month maybe more i
would like look at his twitter just to
kind of see like where is he and
um
you know like just to see like what is
he up to
and um
and i figured out i could tell from the
photographs that he'd moved to
california and i think he might have
told me one of the last times i spoke to
him
that he was gonna move to california but
um and then i also
screen grabbed a lot of stuff that he
put on twitter and he put these creepy
videos of himself on twitter at the
beginning of covid i screen grabbed
those
um
just and then one day i went and like he
was
you know account was suspended
and then i kept going back and it's like
been suspended ever since so he might
have started a new account and i don't i
don't know what it is
probably he's probably in california
you're saying
he is in california that's been
verified somebody who was going to have
to interact with him in an official
capacity
was going to go meet him and i said
and was nervous about it and i said um
he's gonna be really likable like you're
gonna like him he's probably gonna like
figure out what you're interested in
talk sports talk whatever it is that he
figures out quickly that you're
interested in he's gonna be really nice
he's going to seem like a nice guy
and that person later got back to me was
like you're exactly right yeah um so
yeah that's the that's the sociopath
thing right
yeah extremely careful but inside
relationship that's even more dangerous
like so i think that
part of the reason i spoke to him was
entirely self-serving and strategic
after the fact
well even before i knew there was ever
going to be a documentary i spoke to him
and i and i knew how dangerous it was
because i knew that
in a situation like this you're supposed
to have no contact which makes sense and
i understand why which makes it extra
tragic when people have kids with a
sociopath or in a narcissistic abusive
relationship if you have kids then
you're tethered which is tragic
but
why are you supposed to avoid
conversations because you can get pulled
right back so they have no contact yeah
because they'll
continue
abuse or they'll you'll be
vulnerable to them being able to pull
you back in
so i knew that to be the case um
but why was it self-serving why did you
talk to him anyway
because he was getting out
um he was going to be out free out in
the open while i was going to be locked
up at rikers for three and a half months
and the one thing
that you know if his motivation was to
destroy me
then what what else could he do to
really like you know hammer that last
nail in the coffin yeah
that would be leon
and so he would have known that leon
would be staying with my mother
you know he knows where he spent a lot
of time at her house he knows where she
lives it would be super easy for him to
just drive up there
you know
wait
for her to let him out
and then you know he'd because out in
the country
he can be off leash and all he'd have to
do is kind of whistle call him over and
he could take him away and do whatever
so i was completely
like gripped with that fear
so not fear for yourself but fear for
leon
well i was going to be
at least safe from him but i was
going to be locked away so
oh yeah yeah right yeah for sure so i
got it got it gotta get it
i would be powerless to do anything and
he would be have free reign to go
destroy me further by um
you know taking or hurting leon
um
and then when he got out
i
still um i had unfollowed him from my
own account but leon had never
unfollowed him so i
i was looking at i know
i was looking at his um
at his account i just love okay i just
say because because joe has a um
his he hasn't account for his dog too i
just love when people do that it's so
great
because i actually pretend
in my mind for some reason i do think
leon has an account like i don't
you forget that there's a human behind
it you're like oh okay cool yeah
i know i love it when people do that
anyway so continue so leon didn't
unfollow him and what what
so i was able to go back and look at his
twitter and um
he
he somehow he quickly got a phone but he
very quickly started tweeting right
after he got out
and um
and i was kind of like fascinated
because i didn't know
what to expect or what he was going to
be saying and and um
and then he started saying things that i
could tell were directed at me you know
like little things that only i would
know
um you know like random things like
things that were like the equivalent of
like an inside joke that you have just
so he was
posting things like that
and um
there's so many things going on at once
so another thing that would have in a
twisted but i think understandable way
in in sort of a sick way that i was
fully aware of
is that
here i am having gone through this
completely like messed up thing that now
i'm in trouble for everybody's looking
at and nobody understands right
and so there was this unfortunate
situation of the only person who
understands
what i went through
is the person who put me through it yeah
right so
so is it were you also just a little bit
seeking closure of some kind
probably a lot but also with the
awareness that i probably wasn't going
to get it you know and i mean i
i know for a fact i would never get it
in the same way that
which is why
um
which is why i was able to later on
like in the context of recording those
calls
i was able to talk to him
in this detached way
because i know he doesn't give a [ __ ]
that like he doesn't give any shits
about what he did to my mother or me or
anybody or anything just doesn't care so
he's certainly not going to care if i
you know he's never going to say like
i'm sorry or
i did a bad thing or
or like he's not going to be affected if
like if i yelled and screamed at him
that would just be frustrating for me
and he would actually probably be
gratified by that
so
so that that gave you uh that empowered
you in being
cold and sort of
and i had a distant prior experience
where i had to do the same thing where
like if you're if you're able to
be very
cold and not allow somebody to push your
buttons
then you're taking away their power and
then that feels empowering or it feels
like we're claiming a little bit of your
power so
in my talking to him i always had a
reason you know like there was always
like i didn't want him to hurt leon or
i wanted information or i wanted to know
where he was i'd rather let him think
that
you know maybe he could still manipulate
me one day or whatever it was like safer
to keep
that there than to not know where he was
and if i was gonna like
be walking leon and turn the corner and
he's standing there and
you know like it
like if there's a crazy murderer out on
the loose you'd rather know where they
are than have no i have no idea
so there are a lot of different reasons
um why does it upset you
why was it wrong to have that audio clip
at the end of the documentary like what
did it uh well because it implied all
kinds of things that were completely not
true and it also just didn't make sense
and it confused people and
um so
so for people who haven't watched that
spoiler alert as they play the the clip
of
um sorry i don't even remember what was
said but it was kind of
that last what we spoke about yeah what
was the what was that i only watched
like i still haven't watched it i only
watched the film once yeah while
you know people were looking at me for
my reaction and i was crying and it was
really weird and strange and surreal and
i haven't gone back to watch it again i
feel like i'm just gonna get more
annoyed
but i i will eventually but
and when i
when the ending happened i immediately
blurted out like i hate that i hate that
ending but i sort of assumed
a lot of people saw it for what it was
they saw that it was like
the director doing a weird thing and
that it was kind of just weird and off
and like that doesn't make sense yeah it
seemed blue but so it was basically you
joking around like flirting almost it
made it seem like as if we're still
friendly yeah um and there's more to
come it's almost like there's going to
be
a um
bad vegan too
right or
yeah and then also i mean it made it
seem like
you know
if i was laughing with him that i
don't take anything seriously you know
that i don't take what happened
seriously or yeah but it's like all
feeling of remorse exactly
yeah and they after that he goes through
credits with the wild world
which is a great song
yeah oh babies it's a wild world
i never got to hear that because the
version i watched didn't have the end
credits but i knew that they used that
song at the end um
paid a lot for it
you